today on our show man who created the
Joker we all think we know but I think
we found a mystery on the back of an old
comic book page this is something out of
a comic book ladies and gentlemen sit
around and talk to the one man who
discovered perhaps the real secret
origin of the Joker today on fat man on
Batman
but I started collecting comic book art
in the early 90s when Gaston and I were
roommates and and when we were still a
fantastic store him before he left to do
meltdown and I helped him do
construction on the first door who shot
Astros commercial and we bought entire
comic books and Glenn Danzig was
actually the guy that bought entire
comic books full of artwork artwork
cover to cover all the original pages so
I put together the pop sequential ISM
Show and I realized I've written like 80
pages of descriptions because you had to
and and so I thought well I'm not just
gonna put this up online I'm gonna
publish this and so we'd already
published 40 books with love Lew Stacy's
press through last gasp and so we put it
out and you know it's out there in the
world and it's become kind of a price
guide for original comic book art nice I
mean get it at lelou stays calm any
place that carries last-gasp product
they can get it there there's a pop
sequential isn't calm as well but what I
thought was great about this is that it
got me really more interested in okay
what's my follow-up the first one is
just the last 25 years what if I go back
and start like really giving some extra
credit to people who maybe aren't as
worshipped as I think they should be
right and there was a guy who sold comic
art online and his website was obviously
set up at the dawn of the web like Al
Gore era your world wide web and it was
just like an Excel document online and I
just I'd look at this page and be so
frustrating because you'd look at
something and it was too big for the
size of a monitor you have to like slide
over to see okay here's the art the page
number and here's the comic title and
here's the artist not for sale and so
there was like 6,000 pages listed in
this guy's collection and maybe 85% of
them are not for sale so anybody who
went to that website spent two minutes
on it know who's [ __ ] off feel like
this is too frustrating yeah I can't
deal with this and I'm out of here and
center a hunter will we'll study every
half I could smell blood through the
screen I could smell the game and so I
was like it
time my girlfriend was out of town and
I'm like I'm just gonna spend all night
going through this guy's site to see
what's on it and by the time and I
decided to reverse engineer it I went to
the prices first and then just only
looked at was avail what was available
and then scrolled back to the left to
see what it was right so under unknown
were these interesting Batman
preliminary pages displaying preliminary
pages to those literally a preliminary
page is often considered a practice page
it's where an artist will start to
outline what the story's gonna look like
and then for whatever reason switch
gears and go in a different direction
and it doesn't always look like a
completed comic page sometimes it'll
just be pencils and then some ink
studies and blank panels mm-hmm and it
said he had it listed as I think unknown
and it said Batman number number 10 and
then when I opened up his the JPEG it
had listed George Rousseau's question
mark the George versus was the anchor of
Batman for Jerry Robinson good and Jerry
Robinson was the first person to draw
Batman besides Bob Kane really is that
true yeah so he draws he's the very
first person other than Bob can't draw
Batman yeah
he's the father of Robin yep Jerry
Robinson creates Robin when Bob Kane's
like we needed a kid in this book but
kid Bill Finger actually Bill Finger
came up with the idea for Robin and said
that um he thought that it'd be good to
have a kid that the readers could
identify with and Jerry Robinson was a
teenager at the time and he was taking
night classes at UM at a local college
and I think it was my time in Columbia
to double-check but um he figured okay
yeah you know and and he came up with
this idea from he met Bob King I just
read this recently he met Bob came at a
country club he was a kid working at a
country club and he had a jacket on with
drawings that he had done himself and
Bob came as an artist was like that's it
just saying let me see your coat who are
you kid where do you go blah blah and he
said I'm gonna go study at one school
that was not near New Yorker
whatever and Bob came was like it's a
shame you're not studying at Columbia or
whatever because you know I could use
you and he wound up doing that and then
going to work at Bob Kane as a teenager
yeah yeah and noms and Jerry's dad on
the the first movie theater in New
Jersey where it was in oh my god not
Newark Trevon shrine yeah
holy [ __ ] really yeah first movie
theater in Trenton New Jersey how
strange
yeah and his parents played bridge a lot
that's an important part of the story as
well
yes his brother was a professional poker
player mm-hmm and his mother was a
semi-professional bridge player mm-hmm
cards were all around their house no
good to remember that kids that's an
important part of the story later on now
give these cats who are unfamiliar with
Jerry Robinson has done a lot of great
things but one thing he's not known as
is the father of the Joker
who created the Joker according to
comics lore well Bob Kane claimed credit
for decades and would not give up credit
even to Bill Finger um Jerry Robinson
spent a lot of his life getting credit
for Bill Finger Siegel and Shuster yes
and actually he was the person who made
the phone call that actually closed the
deal with Warner Brothers to get Siegel
and Shuster their health insurance and a
bit of a settlement on their their claim
to Superman I think Siegel or Schuster's
wife one of them like sent him back like
it I've read something a letter that
were to telegram whatever [ __ ] going
like you are that most precious of gems
yeah a good friend like he looked out
for those guys yeah and he had also
helped to set up early artist
communities in the 1950s he was brought
in to teach at the cartoonists Institute
which became School of Visual Arts Wow
holy [ __ ] that's SVA cam from the
cartoonist ISM yeah Wow
and so Bern Hogarth was one of the guys
that helped form that school and burn
Hogarth was considered a fine artist but
he also said to the chars and Davison
and so he and Jerry and Will Eisner
would go on the road and do these
lectures about the fine art influence
in comic book art and so Jerry and and
burn would do these drawings and will
would talk and then Jerry would talk and
burn would just keep drawing
could you imagine dude like [ __ ] if
you could buy a ticket for that now how
much money you would pay for watch those
three [ __ ] dudes either talk or
casually draw on a stage and this is the
50s this is like the mid in early fifth
before fandom began before anybody knew
that there was a fandom he had some
dudes who actually did the job going out
there and be like this [ __ ] serious yeah
and so Jerry was constantly working
costly working for other artists rights
help set up a comic book syndicate which
is a service that places comic strips in
international publications not just in
newspapers in the US I'm his son
jens helped set that up when he went to
school in england and they started
placing works that jerry would set up
and he had a team of people his former
students at SVA working with him and
those students included steve ditko
don heck [ __ ] yeah really yeah yeah kids
steve ditko for the uninitiated
spider-man anybody the question [ __ ]
a bunch and Don heck Thor I'm the Hulk
Hulk
I'm sorry Iron Man Iron Man helped
develop Iron Man and I mean and the
other students were no slouches either
and Eric Stanton who was a became a very
famous like bondage comics artist was
also out of that class yeah bookstores
yeah and actually a lot of those are
quite valuable now really yeah a lot of
stuff all right so Jerry Robinson
salt-of-the-earth good guy yeah all
around by all intents purposes you never
met him I never met him you met him in
now but all reports good [ __ ] dude so
these pages that you saw on the dudes
website did they say Jerry Robinson
there was a question mark next to it so
it was George Rousseau's and a question
mark and I'm like George Rousseau's was
an anchor he wasn't a pencil ER and um I
was like some [ __ ] out of Murder She
Wrote right here
this is a Law & Order episode
reverse-engineering you're doing in it
was a front of a page and then two other
pages and then I noticed that one of the
pages had a backside but why I was
interested is my favorite character is
Robin Robin is my all-time favorite
comic character because I feel like I
could be Robin you know that any of us
any of us could be Robin like I'm not an
alien right I'm not a mutant I'm not a
billionaire but if my parents died I
dream of every young child only my
parents would [ __ ] die so I could be
Robin if I was orphaned I could be
adopted by by a millionaire Sanibel
finger was right he was just like we
need somebody in this [ __ ] book for
the kids exactly something to aspire to
but um the other thing is that he's also
very much a veiled archetype for all
children that we all live in the shadow
of our fathers until we become our own
man like that so Dick Grayson you know
throughout the history of the character
becomes Nightwing and I was reading Teen
Titans when that happened and loved
shooters contracts like one of my
all-time favorite and favorite stories
and so I was like well this is an
original there was a prelims of Robin by
the guy that created Robin and I looked
at the prices and they were ridiculously
cheap they were like three hundred and
fifty dollars and seven hundred dollars
and I mean prelims from the 1930s or 40s
are extremely rare in the 1940s
especially 1940-41
any paper that was lying around that
wasn't being used went straight into war
or paper drives the reason that the
mummy movie poster is more valuable than
Dracula and Frankenstein which are far
superior films is because paper drives
ate up all those posters the second that
the film went on a release really yeah
so they're very very rare and comic book
pages the artists that were working on
these and comics are new you know
published bound comic book stories in
that size were new the the strips had
been around but they're only just
starting to bind strips and then
Superman becomes a major hit and you
know national publications is looking at
a follow-up and
Kaine develops Batman and becomes a
thing so Bob Kane wasn't a fast or
particularly adept draftsman so he finds
Jerry Jerry he hires him to ink his
drawings but Jerry ends up redrawing all
the pages like everything he's a
perfectionist yeah and and good you know
and a gifted guy and so bill is is
writing most of the stories Bob's name
is above title and nobody else's name is
on the comic and you know after after
Wilde dick sprang becomes the regular
guy on on Batman and in in detective and
he was an assistant for Jerry Robinson
so I'm looking at these pages and I
happen to open this second view of this
other page and I look on it and so the
front page has what looks to be the
origin of Robin so you've got the flying
Grayson's dying and on the reverse page
and it's not a standard like 9 frame
setup or even like I'll put the picture
up let's put up that first one right
there there's the page of quick yeah
that's the back side of that that's a
busy page particularly for the year it
was made
right and it's too long so that would
not shrink down to standard comic book
page there's an extra line below of
drawings that so this was practice we
really meant any practice yeah and you
snow on the one side of it is the death
of the flying Grayson's you see them on
the tight robes on the trapeze and stuff
this is on that there's there's that
page right there be ready to go back to
the moment just so see them on the
trapeze go back in sorry
the TREB the one we just saw there's the
trapeze image so that's considered the
front of the page yes because that's
what you first so that's a standard
preliminary it's got the right amount of
panels it's it shrinks down to the right
comic book size and on the back of this
was go back to that previous picture was
this yes now take us into it and tell us
why this is interesting maybe we need to
we close up yet let's have everybody
look at it right now what strikes you
about well anybody who's familiar with
the origin of Robin knows that it was
just standard gangsters that boss wasn't
winds up killing his family there's no
clown in that story at all
no none and while it takes place at a
circus no clown is pictured and when
they develop the origin of Robin you're
talking detective 38 that same year
within two months detective
Batman's popularity is such that they
rush Batman she was on title just as
they had previously rushed Superman from
action into Superman and so it's a
really fast exchange and since he was
just a backup character in another comic
they didn't have a lot of stories ready
to go so they had to kind of do double
duty so they knew they were gonna do
four stories for this Batman number one
so Jerry said well I've got this idea
for a really great villain because he
was taking a class on in the adversarial
nature of storytelling mechanics and he
figured that he needed something more
robust than the gangsters that Batman
and Superman reason fighting at that
time what if there was a super villain
and so being in a card playing family
and having access to you know this where
this is going kids you see where the
mystery is coming to he makes a drawing
of a joker that we know comes from 1939
now the UM the first appearance the
Joker in Batman is 1940 it was very
common for people to be ahead knowing
that the publishing schedule was like
four months out and often when you see
the date it's still on comics today it
may be those three months of so it
wasn't any different back then but what
was different was that they loved Bill
Finger was the more experienced writer
and Jerry never written anything before
so when he pitches this idea they're
like well let's give this to bill to do
because he's more experienced and I've
heard that Jerry cried because he was so
disappointed because he wanted us to be
his very thing but that he relented
because he knew it would be better and
it gave him enough time to to illustrate
these other things they still went with
a story a Hugo Strange story in that
first Batman
that was already earmarked for an issue
detective because they couldn't get the
work out fast enough right and bill was
not a particularly fast writer and Bob's
involvement was minor at this point so
when I saw this on Mike there's a clown
there's clearly a clock go back through
that image up of the the close-up
there's the first ones there go to that
other one the second close of the class
what gangster say that's the first
appearance and he's like boss boss
Batman's here okay now no gangster is
calling there's only the clown is
looking at him yep
so it's either that strong man or that
clown that this gangster is saying boss
boss to indicating that that clown is in
charge and heretofore in a Batman book
or any comic book no clown has been a
bad guy or in charge of a gang in
anything this has to be without a
question the secret origin of the Joker
if it's not the Joker it is clearly a
prototype of the Joker and the original
idea was to have that character be
responsible in some way for the death of
Robin Terence that's an even bigger deal
it's not just like hey kids maybe Jerry
Robinson created the Joker but hey kids
we almost had a [ __ ] origin where the
Joker was tied in with Robin yeah so
even after what do you think happened
well because nobody all the players are
gone all the players are gone so here's
what's interesting about this so I start
thinking about this and I'm like okay
well number one this is a preliminary
page which is rare that often in that
time if they weren't going to use the
the images they just erase it and start
all over again right and then I thought
this is an inked preliminary page that's
the thing look at let's throw up those
pictures again man or you can even look
at it yeah see you can see it there we
have it here on there you can see some
pencil and you can see a lot of ink and
it's extremely rare in this era for
anybody to waste ink
what's waste the paper really because
they saw the prices of illustration
board rise in the late 30s and early 40s
because of paper drives so I was
thinking that
this image there's the historic side
you're thinking this image the image
that was on the front which does wind up
in a Batman comic and the retelling of
the Robin origin it's not issue 10 as
this this collector had at least it was
issue 11 but that those panels appear
later in in comic dome so again because
these guys were always on deadline they
were working on multiple projects for
multiple companies why wouldn't they
have just finished that page on the
front because it's very close to the
page that will end up getting published
but for some reason they chose not to
and I don't know if it was because both
Gerry and George realized that this was
an important thing to keep for whatever
reason I don't think it would have been
necessarily for credit and I don't think
that's the kind of guy that Jerry was
and everything that I've learned about
him leads me to believe that he would
not have been doing that but at some
point they figured out that we're gonna
keep this even though it's not published
and it stayed in Jerry's collection at
least until the late 80s early 90s and
how to get out how did you wind up doing
so I found out from Sotheby's that the
pages came from Jerry Robinson that
Jerry or the person who got them from
Jerry Robinson and that what had
happened is that he would routinely
donate comic art for auction for
charities and the types of charities
that you know the heroes initiative
would be taken care of today and it may
have actually been for for raising money
for Segal just grabbing some top [ __ ]
off of power he's like it's fine this
can go and stuff there were three pages
that were part of this collection of
work and I bought two and I left the
third one with the guy because I thought
that if this page winds up being what I
think it is it's gonna be good to leave
that with him right
and you weren't a total pig about it
we're let's [ __ ] rube don't know what
he got I got all your elec here man I'm
gonna take this bubble even but I'm also
sweating and I'm like hiving at this
point like oh my god and this page looks
like it was set up in 1992 and you know
it's probably not even available right
and so I send that I'm like well I can't
just buy these because if I buy all
three of these number one he made
know that the ruse is up and not sell
them they probably not available but if
they are what else can I get and I start
pulling through the rest of the site
stuff that I was looking at and I found
a page that was credited to Vince Caleta
from modern romance it was clearly a
Jack Kirby page and the page is clearly
an influence on Dave Stephens the way
that the girl was drawn it's just such
the Jack Kirby that Dave loved and then
I I found a couple of tarrying the
Pirates dailies and I also found a child
shields peanuts page which had actually
sold when I heard back from the guy so I
do hear back from him mmm and he's like
well you know I I don't accept credit
cards I only accept checks which means
you have to be verified like you have to
you know who do you do business with and
I'm like okay who do I buy coffee I buy
comic book artwork from everybody you
know I buy from and I start running down
the list you know Albert Moy you know
Felix I started naming off all these
guys and he's like oh ya know Felix and
he's like okay so you can send a check
and I was like what can I send you a
business check because I run a galleries
like yeah no problem just have to wait
till the check clears and so I sent it
to him and I'm just like waiting yeah
over 92 and I'm waiting for the pages to
show up and I'm just like ah you know
it's where was it coming here we're in
the world he's in Canada okay and so I
finally get the package and I'm just
like you know put on the rubber gloves
and open up the masonite that it comes
in and the top page is not a page that I
ordered so by the way and then
underneath everything else was fine and
actually what it turned out is that it
wasn't a wrong page of what I ordered
that he accidentally threw in an extra
page and I emailed him to let me know he
had and I sent it back to him and then I
started asking questions like where'd
you get these and he let me know that he
had picked him up at a Sotheby's auction
and I had him email me the UM the
receipt that he got from Sotheby's and I
started to talk to my said you know I
think there might be something to this
page and as I do the the research I'll
let you know and as I started digging
into this and like I say you know
figuring out that this is clearly the
right size paper it doesn't have any of
the earmarks that a fake would have on
it which would be like a DC Comics stamp
which would not have existed at that
point
on the type of ink is clearly India ink
you know it's a type of stuff that these
guys with I mean honestly it's like for
people who are not in the room you've
seen the graphic online but it's [ __ ]
breathtaking to hold a page this old
with sample imagery from a master who
would later go on to make this a piece
of our American mythology like it's
[ __ ] nuts man when you're sitting
there looking at and holding I was just
staring at the images before human being
did this we don't even think of these
cats as human beings as they're their
gods who created gods but it's a kid who
sat down and [ __ ] drew like wonderful
perspective like but this is rough yeah
and this before he even brings his mom
pen to it but it's [ __ ] breathtaking
man but choosing ink it that was kind of
like the real what was game changing
what is the why what do you think why
you wouldn't erase ink if you were gonna
cover it over to reuse but it was like
this is important yeah at some point
really I think that even maybe when it
was done that somebody decided and maybe
it was feedback that the cherry got from
George Rousseau's or maybe even dick
sprang that it was like keep this page
like don't don't sell this like hang on
know who we work for
oh or he understood that it was his and
he wanted it like this was the first
thing I did I got a clown villain I
think it'd be bad it was 19 years old
Wow you know that this was the evidence
that he had created this awesome thing
and he was keeping it for himself and so
I think at some point he just went
through and rifled through a bunch of
pages and just pulled them out this was
on the back you know it might not have
been in the front of the stack it might
not have been in the back of the stack
and he forgot and just like it's one way
probably forgot but you know the more
romantic version is like well it's time
and he just put them out into the
universe and let's just see what have
see what happens leaving it to chance
that is a [ __ ] story and a half to
like holy [ __ ] man a lot what are you
gonna do with the page I asked you on
the podcast but I said put it in lucite
and hang it up in La Luz so everybody
can walk in and [ __ ] say it but what
are you gonna do the thing about yeah
hanging stuff like that
Liuzza's that it would have to be part
of an exhibition because it's
double-sided it would have to be hanging
in the middle of the room and I think it
belongs in a museum
and as I've studied the sale of
important comic book art you see things
like you know the non French record
holder for most expensive comic art sold
was the Todd McFarlane amazing
spider-man where spider-man is holding
up the Hulk yeah and I went for six
hundred and sixty thousand dollars
before the buyer premium so 20% above
that it's what the person paid for it
and that's really both there's a love
Todd McFarlane spider-man in a [ __ ]
Hulk man yeah
and it's certainly a great run but it's
it's not rare there's a lot of Todd
McFarlane covers there's a lot of Todd
McFarlane interior pages and arguably a
better Hulk cover The Wolverine
cover so for that to go for that amount
of money signified that there was enough
interest in the Hobby about
well-rendered artwork and the the record
holder overall is a Tintin Illustrated
cover and that went for over a million
dollars but something like this is I
mean it's a unicorn among unicorns it's
really really rare yeah it's a mystery
you know what's with the the line from
JFK it's wrapped in a riddle trapped
inside an enigma and it's just you know
if this vindicates Jerry Robinson's
claim all these years that he was the
creator of the Joker then that alone
makes it incredibly important but when
it changes the Canon that the Joker may
be responsible or was intended to be
responsible or this prototypical version
of that character is somehow responsible
for the death of Robins parents that
changes everything and what got me back
into collecting comics was an episode of
Simon and Simon in well in 1980s and
there's a comic book that holds the
answer to a real-life murder and it was
the first time I realized that there
could be a number in the middle of a run
that was worth more than a number
and it got me interested and I was like
oh I should look at my comics and I went
I found out that there were comic book
shops and I went and it became my
regular you know Church you know just
going into this comic shop and the guys
that worked in that shop became like my
mentors you know Paul Glavine Paul mark
your Tom sagorsky who became a comic
book professional and a weird man
episode of Simon and Simon trips the
Dominos who knew that the the b-side of
the magnum p.i two-hour block on CBS
thursday night would have such an imp I
guess I'm not tired yet I watched Simon
Simon that [ __ ] led to this do yeah
this is astounding man like what a life
on this [ __ ] guy
a man surrounds himself things he loves
ours he's tripped into and sought after
it been sometimes tripped into amazing
situations but this may be the crowning
achievement in a very interesting
[ __ ] life dude you may have [ __ ]
found something very very important to
those of us who care about this [ __ ]
which right now in the world is
everybody and it's really at the heart
of it is the story of a 19 year old kid
who was just like I think I got my first
I think I got a cool idea that might
have looks like it'd been co-opted and
he didn't quite get the credit for it
man poor Emily deferred at all and was
more interested in getting credit for
his mentor Bill Finger than for himself
really and in the early 90s Bob Kane did
finally relent and say yeah bill finger
help me help me out with the Joker that
was really he was just like yeah you
know always kind of larry is that's does
that Bob Kane himself that's Jerry Jerry
Rob yeah god they look alike don't
Jerry's a little taller I think yeah I
remember that Jerry Robinson yeah that
when I was a boy that was Jerry Robinson
he curated a show in the 1970s in 1975
on comic book art and there was a Mel
Ramos painting of one of his Batman
covers that was then being appraised for
something like 165 million $165,000 so
somebody painted a version of his Batman
cover and that was going for a hundred
six do you think he was just like what
the [ __ ] is like I got paid a hundred
bucks for that at least Jesus Christ
I'm fascinating [ __ ] story man Mac
Kennedy he gives good [ __ ] guest I'm
[ __ ] tell you did a sit on the home
show you aced it on this man plus with
graphics to show people what do you guys
think what is it man and ladies of
course when I said guys I mean both
genders is this what we all think it is
cuz [ __ ] dude it's like what is the you
know they say it's like you eliminate
the impossible and all you're left with
is the possible and I think that there's
obviously there's a lot of fans who
would love this to be the case and what
I wanted to be really careful about in
the research that I've done on this is
to not you know oversell a claim that
there is only a certain amount evidence
that is out there and because all the
principles are dead um the other person
who would have been in the room at the
time is also dead he was an older man
even back then he was the editor who um
I think fine tuned a little bit of the
Robin stuff and he may have been privy
to it but I mean people who are around
talked about it and so when I started
going back and looking for sources to
check things out you'd see people giving
interviews in comic publications and in
illustration publications and in Union
papers for like illustration unions that
they were talk about you know Jerry
Robinson and they would list him as you
know co-creator of not just Robin but
the Joker and other characters so there
were clearly people that were banging
that drum for a long time enough so that
Bob Kane said no he didn't had to go out
and be like no I'm true yeah he's like
I'll give him Robin you know his name is
Jerry Robinson and everybody knows Robin
but he I think that it was bad enough
that he had to relinquish um credit for
not just the Joker but also Batman with
with Bill Finger that um you know one
was enough but you know there's no way
he was gonna split it three ways because
then that made his achievement less and
probably like look I don't know the guy
I never met the guy but I'm sure he was
just like this kid we started him yeah
he's got his whole job and he's Jerry
Robinson because of us we didn't do
anything bad his first employer
work-for-hire yeah wow man it's [ __ ]
nuts
great story go to to shot a great
[ __ ] story they what's the show
that's happened in this weekend a la
lose this weekend is Lindsey way and
Jessica Adams and Jessica yes from jack
off Joe and Scarlett and Lindsey way
from Mindless Self Indulgence and
they'll be opening their show and we've
got five great ladies in the back that
are doing a separate show and it's going
to be incredible it's gonna be amazing
we just got the artwork in tonight we're
hanging it tonight and my life man let
me tell you you're ever in Los Angeles
we're in Los Angeles you haven't gotten
to lose you know you're not Langella
know if you ever come to Los Angeles
make the time go to LA lose Wakko soap
factory it's sublime man it's everything
that you love unloading come on it's
graphically [ __ ] beautiful to begin
with and as good as it looks outside you
walk inside man it's like a Wonka bar
it's all gold on the outside open it up
chocolatey where the golden [ __ ]
ticket there it is what a [ __ ] one
more time because come on how often do
you hold history look at this is I feel
like Nick Cage in that [ __ ] movie
where they broke open the Declaration of
Independence or national treasure see I
haven't even covered this on my own
podcast yet tell them about your
broadcast pod sequential ISM it's on the
meltdown Network and have a lot of
guests on left have you on every week it
launches every Sunday it's on iTunes
it's also on SoundCloud fantastic and
they can get the book at lelou stays
calm and I could see you yeah and come
to whacko so yeah come to wacko buy some
[ __ ] man tell him to [ __ ] it look before
we go out tell me Michael Jackson things
so [ __ ] up Wow okay so I think the
last recorded footage of Michael Jackson
out in public is is him visiting wacko
and he could they call they would always
call ahead I've worked at like three
places where Michael Jackson is called
and they've shut the store down really
yeah a fantastic store originally he
would do that to be wear funny teeth and
he'd bring in sick kids and buy him
whatever they wanted
was great get the [ __ ] out of here
that's really he was a really really
sweet guy and he'd crack kind of
interesting like he had odd sense of
humor
did you say stuff and you just be like
that's Michael Jackson I'm not a react
to it yeah and but he came in and he
shopped and I think he had he had his
kids with them as well and there was
some other kids and he had the hood on
and he had the fake teeth and he bought
a bunch of stuff and he also bought an
original art piece Brian poor mechanical
piece and it became covered by the
tabloids and it was that was the last
place he was publicly before that yeah
and it was on the when you call that
that show that the paparazzi show TMZ
Ranna thinks they ran video on it and
Michael Jackson is huge the world over
and I mean he was always big in the US
but I mean he's got almost like Masonic
status in other places getting a pop yes
and there's a Japanese tour group that
comes to the gallery I love like every
second Tuesday and like a little minivan
and they come and visit and they look at
the receipt they've saved the receipt
it's at wacko behind the register it's
hanging there the receipt and it's long
long is you're like Scott bought a lot
of [ __ ] it's like four feet long and um
and they come in and they look at it and
they see what they can afford and they
buy the same items that are on Michael
Jackson receipt in that amazing I'm
stealing that putting that in a movie
it's so [ __ ] real it's beyond real
that's nuts dude they look at the
receipt and they're like well I guess we
could afford this you could also make it
about prints
I've only seen him in public once and it
was that well twice at glam slam when he
ran the club and he would just sometimes
perform for hours like after hours
really yeah you'd walk in and he'd be
like shut the music down like killed the
the dance music and get up and play and
then I saw him at Coachella but still
like a badass SEMA glam slam that's
poking likes that's like living in
purple rain yeah
goddamnit you're lucky summer there's
anyone in this world I want to be other
than Kevin Smith it's Matt Kennedy he's
been our guest here today on fat man and
I'm Batman man let us know what you
think you think this is the real deal
it's gotta be who the [ __ ] who stands
against this you know what I'm saying
after this last hour if you're not like
you know what I'm pretty sure Gerry
Roberts it also created the Joker then
you must be a Nazi robot there it is
thanks for hanging out with us thank you
for coming and doing the story again
this time with graphics and stuff and
standing the whole time last time we sat
for hours yes that blaze and [ __ ]
talk it's a great podcast go listen to
it that's over smart gets that come
thanks for hanging out with us here
today I'm fat man I'm Batman man I've
been Kevin Smith this is Matt Kennedy go
visit la Luz de Souza in Los Angeles and
come back next would've them next
episode right here
same bat-time same bat-channel smart
guest icon / Kevin Smith
hey Nance me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder